[Music]
do it um
i love it i love this job more than my
actual paid job
and i think that's because you can
be
you you can kind of make the role you
want it to be yes there's meetings and
yes there's you know certain things that
you have to follow but you can make it
how you want to be not to be frightened
of the idea of it it feels like a big
thing from the outside and it is a very
important thing but you do get lots of
support and you do learn as you go along
it's you know one of those jobs that you
can't go in with all the knowledge and
skills and experience you have to build
it up don't be afraid to do it it's it
is a big jump and you sometimes think
you know what am i doing i don't have
any experience in this field but don't
ever let that hold you back because that
is something that is actually you bring
something that someone else doesn't have
the main thing about being a counselor
is you're a bridge between
your residence and the council and
obviously when you become a councillor
you you have access to people
who can help um so it's yeah it's just
making contacts it's all networking
isn't it and um yeah
joining the dots if you want to have
um you know concentrate a lot on your
case work and you want to do a lot of
the community engagement so i think you
can do that if you want to concentrate
on
the policy side of work and you know
what the organization does as a
structure for the whole of planet you
can also do that
you can go into research there's loads
of different opportunities that you can
make it your own i suppose i think any
experience you can bring i don't think
you need to have done a particular job
or even been sort of politically active
before you just need an interest in the
local area and the local people and who
knows you could be the next leader
[Music]